joyeux anniversaire veut je souhaite
devenir astronaute
oui astronautes ou alors pompiers oui
pompiers c'est bien probable
le camion oui le camion revoir des super
pouvoirs et le camion c'est super ça
dinosaures commence à dinosaures ou
courbes pour être un dinosaure enfin je
comprends pas où avoir un dinosaure
je sais pas on aimait dinosaures c'est
plus c'est trop cool les dinosaures puis
peut-être que je pourrai me marier avec
les apu tarawih qui croît lui faire un
bisou la tête à l'envers dans notre
camion qui sera dans l'espace allez
souffle nicolas vas-y souffle elle
souffle
chance de l'autre je met à tomber
anniversaire nico joyeux anniversaire
dépêche toi
[Musique]
je souhaite faire du bon gros rock kraft
sans oublier de sauver des gens d'un
incendie en parallèle comme ça c'est
toujours ça en temps mais bien sûr
rockstar et on sauve des gens en péril
les deux combinés ces styles et ouais ça
va trop vouloir sortir avec moi c'est
sûr que comme ça que vous avez phase
avec les approuver se marier nous
écoutent les halles a déménagé à la fin
du cm1 à valenciennes dont qu'est ce
qu'on fait on prend un billet de train
on va dans une ville qu'on connaît pas
on sait pas où elle habite on lui a
parlé cinq fois de notre vie
ou alors on serait clos et abat on sort
avec chloé quoi ah non mais t'as pas ni
de quoi qu'est-ce que les et qui sont
venus mais tu sais très bien on va pas
devenir astronaute
mais pourquoi qu'est ce qui vous fait re
prêtre astronautes ont fait des tests
n'ayant ça oui oui ok non mais oui on
fait des études supérieures
non mais c'est pas longtemps 7 8 ans et
pas non plus ses études c'est mort de
chez moore franchement alors que pour
être rock star suffit de faire la
guitare a dû astronautes quoi mais c'est
n'importe quoi peut pourquoi pompiers il
reste que tout le monde sait que c'est
populaire auprès des filles et nous on
va enfin surtout clowe est surtout plus
super sympa les gars et dinosaures qui
reste ça on m'explique ah non mais moi
je suis là que corps ni qu il est
défoncée peut partir astronautes
nicolas il croyait
c'était notre rêve
[Musique]
je me permets d'insister mais super
héros c'est pas mal hein mais toi tu
payes domaine tu dégages en fait à
j'aurais été sur mais bon j'ai tenté
salut moi c'est testeur de jeux vidéo
voit génial trop bien beaucoup mieux que
spider man grave et nico souffle et
souffle nico bézy souffle
nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
joyeuse anigo
[Applaudissements]
m
je souhaite faire le tour du monde
rencontrer des cultures s'enrichir des
expériences humaines mieux comprendre le
monde qui nous entoure pour mieux se
comprendre savoir notre diplôme de
comptabilité mais c'est pas un rêve ça
ma grosse que vu nos résultats au
dernier semestre si on arrive à valider
notre année ça me remet man c'est pas un
diplôme qui va nous ouvrir sur le monde
qui nous entoure et avec quel argent va
partir le en travaillant l'été les
vendanges le
on a un plan la mairie oui super la vie
faire des petits boulots tout cas quels
lendemains bien ont validé à temps parce
que moi j'ai parlé avec morgane elle
adore les voyages
si je vous dis que j'ai fait un tour du
monde je vais à pécho ah ouais c'est
important un an qu'on va réussir à
sortir avec on va revenir sera fiancée
avec quelqu'un on aura l'air content
en fait réalistes les gars faut se
réveiller un petit peu fort un plan de
carrière c'est important tu fais quoi
ben les autres à il ya d autres qui pond
pierrot que pompier ou faut être
réaliste si faire combien de pompe une
bombe au monde voilà les rockstars la
guitare qu'on était offerte annuel des
jeux comme une fois mais ça fait hyper
mal ou douala les cordes après sur
guitar hero on a fait free bird en
difficile ce qui est pas dégueu et mon
petit niveau
ah ouais d'accord toi tu veux parler toi
testeur de jeux vidéo ça n'existe pas
c'est pas un métier c'est un loisir il
faut un diplôme beau avoir un métier
comme être comptable par exemple tu
n'existes pas
[Musique]
après si on boit trois quatre bières moi
je peux revenir super super responsables
ont bien joué les gars mais à rennes
nous faire chier man c'est notre
anniversaire on a le droit de rêver
vas-y souffle nicolas et je te jure un
jour on va le faire ce tour du monde
asie sauf
[Musique]
j'attendrai streaming j'en ai entendu
parler
les anniversaires chaîne à doha elle
souffrait
[Musique]
je souhaite une augmentation non j'étais
pas partis là-dessus ça fait quand même
quatre ans connor à boitant pardon mais
qui prime serait pas de refus exactement
et puis ça pourrait nous aider à monter
un dossier d'emprunt morgan nous dit
souvent qu'elle aimerait partir en
vacances il nous faut de l'argent
sinon ça sent pas bon pour le couple
excuse moi vous vous êtes qui voient ces
augmentations propriétaire ok oui
globe-trotteuse jamais entendu parler
une prime ce serait bien j'ai vu un
petit peu les prix des appartements lieu
ça grimpe pas bien en ce moment
oui peut-être que la banque peut nous
faire un tour pas trop dégueu
franchement j'y crois pas vu les marchés
actuels fois peut-être passer par
[Musique]
avant j'étais très tendu bah oui sa
patiente
tu exagères que c'est une fiat multipla
et de codes nucléaires
attends qu un pack d'eau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'elle devienne propriété as le tour du
monde et le monde
elle va le voir tourner depuis son hub
l'ol va enregistrer des albums dans
l'espace dans l'espace bon pote métro m1
et si elle se faisait mordre par une
araignée radioactive
ouais ouais et elle aura un camion je me
permets d'insister parce qu investir
dans la pierre c'est quand même un bon
moyen ou fermer sa gueule
elle va faire des trucs incroyables pour
être avocat qui sera la première à
marcher sur ma foi qu'ils délivrent elle
va construire des ponts il va nous faire
rêver le vice-président d'eads va avoir
un prix nobel
ou alors est au chômage comme papa elle
fera son choix et ce sera non
[Musique]